modern furniture began
at the bauhaus 100 years ago
there have always been only a few
serious companies doing bauhaus
furniture re-editions or replicas we're
doing this for 50 years now it's
important for us to tell the story how
it really was
[Music]
this is tecta a factory in lone photo
germany one of the few in the world to
replicate original bauhaus furniture
and this is one of the crafters behind
it all
my name is christian rescher i'm the
owner of tekta
we are family business fourth generation
and i co-worked with my
uncle axel beauhouser for the last years
my father and i we took over then
the existing camera detector and our
dream was to produce all the forgotten
bauhaus
furnitures
our aim is to to prove every day that
these classics still play a role in
current living situations the
centenarian designs are known for their
minimal and practical nature and lack of
adornments and details central features
in the bauhaus school and these men are
on an intricate mission to make sure
designs like the 1925 wassily chair and
the 1927 cantilever chair are still sat
on today
drawings and and original
documentations are very important so we
work to closely or work closely with
bows archive and then from that on we
can realize things we have a carpentry
workshop the metal workshop with the
upholstery so all these together
together with a designer
this makes it possible to make the
furniture
it's a
big satisfaction if you see that you
have
somehow prolonged the life cycle of an
old classic by doing an interpretation
of 2019 of a powerhouse piece from 1919
it's and then people say wow this is so
evangedistic this is so contemporary
though it's 100 years old that that
makes us very proud because they are not
simple products they are furniture with
the soul
with something more
[Music]
you